hey there welcome to selenium-webdriver
tutorial by simply lung my name is
Annika and today in this video we'll be
talking about the selenium-webdriver
basics what is that you should be
expecting from this video let's see what
a selenium whenever we are learning
about any tool it good to know a little
bit brief history of it so we will look
into how selenium has evolved over years
to become the most popular web
application automation - and why use
webdriver
and then we will understand what the
selenium driver while we learn this I
will also be touching upon some
drawbacks of manual testing and how
automation helps and then a deep dive
into architecture of webdriver as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the limitations of
selenium webdriver
and how we work around us and then I
will demonstrate the webdriver in action
for which I will use a simple web
application use keys to automate so
let's get started so before we talk
about selenium let's understand a few
drawbacks of manual testing let's take
an example of a very simple use case as
a user I want to login to my web
application using username and password
a very simple use case and it's a very
common use case for any kind of web
application you're working so as a
tester what do I do
I need to write multiple test case to
the test this use case so I can use
multiple data sets like valid
credentials invalid credentials null
values and so on to test this particular
use case and then what you do you start
executing the test cases one by one you
find bugs then your developers fixes
them and then you will need to rerun all
the test cases again and again until all
the bugs are for this use case are fixed
and your application is ready to ship
now look into this now this brings us to
the first merit demerit of the manual
testing which is what if one has to run
test cases with hundred transactions and
repeat them again and again this is
going to be a very time-consuming
process and very boring also it is more
error-prone since it's done manually and
human mistakes are bound to happen the
third challenge is the scope of manual
testing itself is very limited for
example say regression testing ideally
you would want to run all the test cases
which you have written but
since it's a manual process this is
going to be very tedious to do and also
you would not have all the luxury of
time to execute all test cases so what
do you do you start picking up those
test cases which are very important to
be run and that way you are kind of
limiting the scope of your testing also
working with large amount of data
manually is going to be impractical what
about performance testing you want to
collect metrics on various performance
measure as a part of your performance
testing you want to simulate multiple
loads on your application under test and
all these things manually it is very
difficult to perform and it's not
feasible also and to sum it all this
creating manual test reports after
running all the tests who wants to
really do that and again another level
of challenge here is say if you're
working on an agile model where code is
being churned out by developers the
testers are building their test cases
executing them as and when the bills are
available to them this happens I turret
Emily and hence you will need to run all
those test cases which you have written
multiple times during your development
cycle and doing this manually definitely
is going to be very tedious employed and
is this an effective of doing it no so
what do we do we automate it so this
tells us why we want to automate one for
faster execution - to be less
error-prone three to help frequent
execution of our tests so there were
many tools available in the market for
automation one such tool was selenium
and that brings us to the slide advent
of selenium so much before selenium the
various tools in the market like rft qtp
just to name a few popular ones the
selenium was introduced by a gentleman
called Jason Huggins way back in 2004 he
was an engineer at ThoughtWorks
he was kind of working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
in doing manual testing of his
application repeatedly so what he did
was he wrote a JavaScript program that
automatically controlled the browser
actions and then he named that as
JavaScript test run he made this open
source which was later renamed the
selenium core and this is how the
selenium came into existence so with
this brief history of selenium let's
understand what the selenium and what
are its main features selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tool for automating web applications
it enables us to test web application on
different kind of process like Internet
Explorer Chrome Firefox Safari Opera and
so on and also they introduced support
for edge browser after Microsoft
introduced it selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web applications it is not a single
tool it has multiple components and
those we will be seeing in some time all
these tools together helped us test the
web application so selenium is open
source and it is platform independent
this is the biggest reason why people
are preferring this tool because it is
free of cost QT p and r FD which I just
talked about are a chargeable one
selenium scripts can run on any platform
because selenium is primarily developed
in Java scripts so it is platform
independent well as you know it's common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming background so selenium has a
record and replay back tool called the
selenium IDE which can be used to create
a set of actions as a script and to
replay that script but this is mainly
used for demo purpose why because
selenium is such a powerful tool that
you should be able to take advantage of
all its features and not just be with a
record and replay told rate so that's
where there are a lot of record and
replay tool anyway available in the
market the selenium provides support for
different programming language Java
Python c-sharp Ruby PHP and so on you
can write your test scripts in any
language you prefer or you like and
again as I said one need not really know
in depth or advanced knowledge of these
languages you would still be able to
write the selenium scripts with a basic
knowledge of this programming language
and also selenium supports various
operating system you can run selenium
tests on Windows Mac or Linux or even
say if you have a one two machine you
can always run your selling em test on
Ubuntu machines so or you can run the
test on any platform of your choice okay
so let's go now a little more deeper
into selenium so I said that selenium is
not a single tool but it is a suite of
tools right so now let's look at what
are those major components which
comprises of the selenium suite first
one is the selenium ID so selenium ID is
the most simplest tool in the whole
suite of the selenium it is nothing but
it's an in
a great development environment earlier
this IDE was simply a Firefox extension
and it offered a recording playback
functionality it was a very simple and
easy to use and as I said mainly this is
used for prototyping or for only the
demo purposes right and not creating
automation for your real-time projects
because you know of its own limitation
of being a simple record and reflective
however selenium what happens selenium
IDE it died with Firefox 55 so that
means the support for ID was stopped
from Firefox 55 version but the good
news is very recently all new brand new
selenium ID has been launched and also
what they have done is they've made this
cross browser that means you can install
the extension on Chrome the ID extension
on Chrome or as an add-on on Firefox
Otis supported on both the browsers
Firefox and Chrome on it so while
talking of this ID let me also show you
how the latest ID on the chrome looks
okay for that let me go and launch my
Chrome browser so let me just open a new
tab and what I'll do is I'll search for
selenium ID for chrome download then I
go to this website then you can see a
selenium IDE offered by selenium HQ or G
so what I simply need to do is like you
install any extension on your Chrome
browsers I just say active chrome and
this adds this extension on your Chrome
browser now it has added so selenium IDE
has been added to Chrome use this
extension by clicking the sides then so
can you see this icon here which is
selling MIT that's it so once you have
installed this you are free to start
using the idea on this Chrome browser
similarly you can do adding of this
add-on which is called a side on on
firefox so go to the firefox browser
search for the selenium ID and just
install that add-on so let's get back to
our presentation so that's about the ID
so what's the next component an X
component of selenium RC which is
nothing but selenium remote control
selenium RC is used to write web
application tests in different
programming languages it interacts with
the browser with the help of RC server
it has an RC server through which only
it can interact with the web process and
how does it communicate it uses a simple
HTTP GET and post requests and this is
what was
called a selenium 1.2 version but it got
deprecated into dot abortion and it was
completely remodeled 3 dot o and was
replaced with something called s
webdriver so we will be talking in
detail about why this happened what were
the drawbacks of RC which led to
replacing with the webdriver so now that
brings us to the third component which
is the selenium by webdriver
this is the most important component it
is just a programming interface to
create and execute our test cases of
course it's a successor of RC because
there were certain drawbacks which I
just mentioned and we will be going in
detail of what it was
so webdriver what the major difference
what we see with the webdriver is the
architecture of the webdriver is much
simpler than RC for the reason that
webdriver interacts with the browser
directly unlike your RC where it means
an RC server to interact with the
browser so this gave a lot of advantage
and edge over the RC the fourth company
selenium grid selenium grid is used to
run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with selenium
driver you can only do the sequential
execution however in the real-time
environment you know that there is
always a need to run tests on
distributed environment for example say
you have a web application and say you
have automated or on hundreds or
thousands of test cases and you need to
run them as a regression suite and also
one of the ask is that you need to run
this on multiple browsers and multiple
OS why since you have automated them and
your application suppose multiple
browsers and worse
now imagine the time taken to run these
thousand test cases sequentially with
the webdriver right it's going to take
quite a bit of time so what you need is
to run this parallel on multiple
machines matrix that cross the browsers
and operating system and that is where
the grid helps you in achieving that so
grid has this hub and node concept and
it helps in achieving the parallel
execution which I just talked about so
you can check out our detailed video on
selenium Krypton simply laughs all right
so now we talked about the competence of
the selenium so let's look at the
different versions it evolved into so
when I talked about RC I mentioned that
this was selenium one version so now
let's understand how this evolved over
years and what it offers today so when
Jason Huggins
introduce selenium the tool was called
JavaScript program he called it as
JavaScript test Runner it had one major
issue now that does something called a
same origin policy so what does the same
origin policy it says that a JavaScript
when executed in a domain can access
webpages in that domain only and it
cannot access any webpages in another
domain I will repeat it same origin
policies dictates that a javascript is
executed in a domain can access webpages
in that domain only and it cannot access
webpages in another domain for example
say every web page inside google.com to
me like search email drive can be
accessible but nothing outside of
google.com like say if you want to
access a web page and say Amazon or
Yahoo is possible to access why because
of the simple reason which is a security
reasons now to overcome this Paul Holman
created something called a selenium
remote control server and why did he
create that he wanted to trick the
browser in believing that the selenium
core through which you are going to run
your scripts and your web application
under test are in the same domain with
which you were able to achieve run your
tests on your web application without
having to get into this issue same
origin policy so this is what was a
version 1 of selenium and we called it
as reverse selenium remote control and
then what happened in 2007 Simon Stewart
ok he invented this webdriver now why
did he invent this because the
architecture of selenium RC was little
complicated RC required a separate
server to talk to your browsers so what
he did was he removed the requirement of
having a separate server in the RC and
this was the selenium 2 version now
since it was a transition phase both the
selenium RC and the webdriver coexisted
in selenium 2 while the webdriver was
still under development and then what
happened in 3.0 selenium is the selenium
core which is the RC was completely
deprecated and only the web driver was
made available so in this series of
videos we will be working with selenium
3 dot and now selenium 4 is already
around the corner so alpha is already
released
as of the deal in this video was made
and I believe some of the features what
the selenium 4 is going to offer is they
are moving towards w3c webdriver
standardization one and also there is
going to be an improved ID the ID which
I just talked about that it's a improved
version of the previous ID and then an
improved version of selenium grid also
so they might be doing the GUI based
grid right so these are some of the
major features expected in this version
while selenium webdriver so let's look
at what led to replacement of selenium
RC with this webdriver for that first we
need to understand the selenium RC and
it's shortcoming as I said selenium RC
is a simple tool to write tests for web
applications in various supported
programming languages like Java Python
Ruby and C shot and this is the
architecture of the selenium RC at a
very high level first you need to write
test scripts in any of the supported
languages of your chest so if you're
more familiar with Java you will be
writing your test scripts all your
commands in the chavala so before we
start writing the test
one of the major requirement it required
for the RC to run is your RC sober so
first you need to start this RC server
before you run even a single line of
code and this RC server is a separate
application and now what is the function
of this RC server the selenium server
for the RC server is responsible for
receiving Cellini's commands from your
test script it interprets them and then
reports the result back to your selenium
test now what are the Cellini's commands
these commands are nothing but the
commands returned in your test code
these are called as Cellini's command
that is what the selenium server does
now after the selenium servers function
let's look at how the browser
interaction happens the browser
interaction happens through this RC
server this RC server uses a simple HTTP
POST and get request to communicate and
how does this communication happen this
RC server acts like a proxy say for
example your test scripts asks for
launching a browser this command from
your test script goes to the server and
then this RC server launches the browser
injects as Java scripts into the browser
once this is done all the subsequent
costs that is all the subsequent calls
is all the rest of the commands which
you have written after
launching the browser go to this RC
server and then to the actual web server
so it routes all the commands are
getting routed through your RC server to
your web browser upon receiving this
instruction so what does a cor do it
execute this command as the JavaScript
commands on your browser so once these
are executed the response from the
browser or the results what you say are
sent back to the RC server and RC server
is responsible for sending it back to
your desk and then the test results are
displayed here now if you see this
complete cycle from starting your
command from your test script talking to
the RC server then RC server talks to
the web browser it injects the
JavaScript here runs your command takes
back the results sends it to RC server
and then back to this test script this
whole cycle gets repeated for every
command which is written in your desktop
and this is how your test case gets
executed all right so now everything is
fine so great we are unable to run the
scripts we were able to launch the
browser we are able to execute all the
commands so what was the problem here
why was still RC not good enough for the
reason why the RC was still not good
enough was one the architecture of RC is
very complicated because of that
intermediate RC server to communicate
with the browser so there is no direct
interaction with the browser this RC
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts that means it
has an additional setup because that is
RC server is a mediator between your
selenium commands and your browser the
execution of the commands takes very
long time it is very slow why because we
saw that every command written in our
test scripts needs to make a full trip
from your test script to the RC server
to the code to the browser and then back
which makes your overall automation test
execution very very slow so how the
selenium webdriver now overcomes this
this is a simple architecture of
selenium webdriver
even in webdriver we have test scripts
we have a web browser and a web server
however we do not have an additional
server for communication make the RC
server which we saw in the selenium RC
this makes the architecture of webdriver
very simple the selenium webdriver
that's one of the biggest advantages the
selenium webdriver
does not use an additional server then
secondly it makes direct calls to your
browser using your browser's native
support automation so since there is no
intermediate server there the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level itself now due to this
direct communication the overall the
trips what we saw from the RC server to
the browser and from the browser back to
the RC server and to the test strips
right this was an indirect communication
since this whole thing was awarded the
speed of test execution is much faster
in RC and this overall architecture of
the web driver if you see is much much
simpler than what the RC provides so
this was the major drawback from the RC
and this is where web driver replaced RC
know was that all because of the
architecture no there were few other
shortcomings with the RC aps in selenium
RC a single function has several
commands redundant and confusing a PS RC
is less object-oriented API though there
are good set of ApS to work with they
are pretty redundant and confusing for
example how and when to use a type key
or a type command another example is the
Mouse commas click or to use click at or
when to use Mouse at or Mouse top so
this was getting pretty confusing for
the developers and to top it all this
every browser interprets the command
differently which makes your test cases
brittle when it has to work on the
multiple browsers developers had a tough
time making their scripts cross browser
and they had to add browser specific
code whereas selenium driver comes with
a set of more matured and simpler API
which are pretty straightforward to use
for example a simple click to simulate a
click action on any web element send
keys which simply means send the text to
any web element on your web page scroll
up or down on the web page and so on so
we will see more of this commands when
we actually start working with the web
driver another difference is the browser
support do both RC and webdriver
supports multiple browser RC does not
have support for HTML unit which is a
headless browser whereas the web driver
supports testing on headless browser now
what is the seedless browser headless
browser is a browser which does not have
a UI it makes testing much faster
because it does not need a
your browser for testing now to
summarize all this so if you look at the
RC and the webdriver comparison which we
talked about RC is a complex
architecture whereas webdriver has a
simple architecture for the main reason
that webdriver removes the need of
having an intermediate server RC the
execution of your test cases or your
automation scripts it's much slower than
the webdriver RC requires a RC server to
interact with the browser whereas the
selenium webdriver interacts with the
browser directly using the web drivers
also we saw the APS which RC provides
which are pretty confusing and web
drivers we have much easier and easy to
use aps no support for HTML unit browser
which is ahead let browser selenium
driver also provides support for HTML
unit Raza now that we have understood
what selenium are seals and why
webdriver replaced RC let's go another
level deeper into webdriver so what is
selenium webdriver we know that the
webdriver in its simplest term is a tool
or a programming interface to create and
execute test cases on a web application
it supports multiple browsers ie Firefox
Chrome Opera Safari edge and it also has
support for headless browser so we will
know in some time what is an headless
browser some of the features of
webdriver so while RC was introduced in
2004 webdriver got introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006 webdriver can run on any
platform of your choice Linux Windows
Mac and even if you have a window
machine you can run your selenium web
rack and what does the actual webdriver
is it an ID no it is a simply and
programming interface to run your test
cases and how does it work the test
cases are created and executed using web
elements on the objects using web
locators and webdriver methods so once
we get into the demo or once you start
understanding how selenium book you will
understand what are these webdriver
methods and the locating techniques
which are used to perform these actions
on web element selenium webdriver is
pretty fast
why since the web driver interacts
directly with the browser and does not
have an intermediate server like RC each
browser with
but you want to work with has its own
driver on which your application runs
and this driver is responsible to make
the browser understand the command which
are being passed from your script like a
click of button or entering some text in
any of the input fields through your
scripts you tell which browser you want
to work with say you want to do all this
actions here on the Chrome browser if
you want to work with Chrome browser
then the chrome driver is responsible
for interpreting your instructions from
your test case and executing them on the
web application which is launched or
Chrome browser earlier so like our C web
driver also supports multi programming
languages in which you can write your
test scripts like the ones which are
listed here also web driver supports
different frameworks like test ng J unit
and n unit when we talk about the
limitations of webdriver
you will appreciate how the support for
various frameworks and tools help in
making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
now let's try to know what is the
architecture of selenium webdriver
webdriver has four different components
in it one we have the client libraries
or what is also called as language
binding since I said selenium supports
multiple languages and you are free to
use any of the supported languages to
create your automation script there are
libraries available on selenium website
which you need to download and use that
let me show you that so let's go to my
Chrome browser so I have the selenium HQ
website already launched here so guys if
you're working on selenium this website
selenium h cubed over G is going to be
Bible so everything and whatever you
need to know and work with selenium is
available here for now we want to see
the client library so the language bunny
so for that what you need to do is if
you go to the download section here can
you see your the selenium client and
webdriver language binding so for each
of the languages which is supported you
have a client library which you can
download from here so if you are working
on Java you need to download the Java
libraries if you're working on Python
you need to download the Python
libraries right so these are called as
language bindings so selenium provides
lot of aps for us to interact with the
browsers and when we do the demo I will
be showing some of those aps now what
are these ABS these ApS are
rest appears rest is representational
state fill ApS and everything for
selenium happens to this rest cause the
second component is the json wire
protocol so what is jason javascript
object notation and it's a standard for
exchanging data over the world so for
example you want to launch a web
application through your script so what
selenium does is it creates a JSON
payload and post the request to the
browser driver right and where are this
browser driver these are here right and
what are these browser drivers these are
a driver specific to each browser so if
you see here you can see drivers for
Chrome Firefox Opera Safari and edge
right so we interact with the actual
browsers here using these drivers and
how does this happen
this driver establishes connection with
the real browser without revealing the
internal logic of browser functionality
if that's exactly the function of this
browser trailer now what does that mean
let's say we want to execute a test
screen so what happens when the script
is executed is an HTTP request is
generated and sent to browser driver for
each command in the script and then the
driver receives the request through this
HTTP server and does all the execution
on the actual browser once the execution
is done the execution results are just
sent back over the same HTTP server to
your test scripts so this is the
simplest form of the architecture of the
selenium webdriver well now as every
tool has its own advantages and its
limitations so let's look at what
selenium limiting webdriver limitations
are cannot test mobile applications
requires framework like IBM selenium is
for automatic web application it cannot
handle mobile weight mobile applications
are different and they have its own set
of automation tools however what
selenium provides is a support for
integrating this APM tool IBM tool is
one of the popular tool for mobile
application automation right so it
provides a support for integrating APM
tools so using APM and selenium you can
still achieve mobile application
automation now when do you usually use
this in cases where say your application
under test is also supported on mobile
devices so that means you need
can ISM to run your test cases on your
web browser as well as your mobile
browsers right and this is how you
achieve it using selenium when we talked
about components of selenium I said that
the webdriver can achieve only
sequential execution but in real time we
know that we just cannot live with this
we need to have a parallel execution on
multiple machines and on multiple
browsers so this limitation of webdriver
is replaced by having the grid which
helps us in achieve the parallel
execution and do check out our video on
more details on selenium grid selenium
webdriver has limited reporting
capability it can help create basic
reports but definitely we need more
especially when we are working on a big
project we need good reports to be
created so what it does is we have a
support for multiple tools like test ng
report ng and even the extent reports
which you can integrate with selenium
and generate beautiful reports isn't it
really powerful all right there's
another challenge what we have these are
amongst few of the challenges what I
have put across here there are other
challenges also but always there is a
workaround to get through those
challenge so another challenge which we
have mentioned here the selenium is not
very good with image testing especially
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium to achieve
any kind of image testing you want to do
like Auto it and securely so same way
the way it provides a mechanism to
integrate APM so selenium also provides
a way for integrating auto it and the C
kill'uh tools so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for automation li and that's
the beauty of selenium that makes it
most powerful tool today for automation
ok so let's look at webdriver in action
so before we do that let's understand
some of the basic browser commands and
functions that we will be using in our
demo today the gate commands so there
are six gate commands to perform various
actions on the browser driver dot get
this is used to launch any website
application it takes a string argument
and this needs to be a fully formed URL
which you want to launch driver dot get
title so this method fetches the title
of the webpage which you are working
with so for example let's go to Ebay so
if you just
over your mouse here can you see the
texture electronics cars fashion
collectibles coupons and more eBay so
this is nothing but title of this
current pitch and this command helps us
to get that title get current URL so to
get the URL of any page is when you want
to use this command so this will be used
especially when you are working with
multiple web pages and you want to say
print whatever the current URL you're
working on on the console get paid
source this method dumps the complete
HTML page source on your console
actually this is not really much used
unless you really need to look at
anything in your HTML pages and then
there are two more gate commands related
to Windows handles these are used for
handling multiple tabs and multiple
windows on the browser now we will not
be dealing with this in today's demo
however if you want to know the details
of this command
these are available in our video
tutorials for this commands the next set
of commands are the navigational
commands so these are self-explanatory
and basically are used to navigate
between the multiple pages of your web
application the first one the driver dot
navigate dot 2 is very similar to driver
dot get so both does the same function
and then you have navigated back never
did code for word and navigate dot
refresh so this is used for refreshing
your browser page and then there are two
commands browser commands which we use
one is the driver dot close so this
closes the current browser window so if
you have got multiple tabs open in the
window and you want to close a
particular tab so that is when you use
driver door close and driver dot quit
what it does it quits the entire process
session then there are few other
commands and these some of the commands
are listed here however if you see there
is a huge list of commands available in
selenium and since we'll be using just a
few of them in today's demo I have
listed here so let's just understand
these very basic commands which we will
be using driver dot find element now
when you want to work with any
application what is that you need to do
you need to perform actions on the
elements of the web page and these are
called as web elements for example let's
go to our email so on this website say
you want to search for JBL speakers and
what do you do when you want to search
for this you would identify the search
box and you will enter the text JBL
speaker
right and then you go ahead and click on
the search button so this is the set of
operations which you will do now for us
to write this and this is exactly what
you need to do through your commands for
us to really write this text as JBL
speakers i need to know what this
particular element is okay so this
particular input box is my web element
which i need to identify similarly if i
want to click on the search button i
need to identify what this button is and
that's exactly is done by using driver
dot find element selenium has multiple
ways of finding this elements it has
eight element locating techniques and
our future videos on selenium do cover
these eight element locating techniques
were very much in detail so for us right
now we will be using couple of them so
one is with ID and one is with a link
text the next one
the send keys so as the name indicates
it is used to send a certain text to any
web element you have identified or you
want to work like in this example as I
said since we want to search for JBL
speakers right I would be basically
sending the text JBL speakers to this
web element using send keys click so
after entering the text what we need to
do I say we need to click on the search
button so for all such actions we have
methods defined in selenium and one of
them is this click what this does is it
just clicks on the web element or the
button which we want to work with so now
with these basic commands let's go ahead
and start writing our code for our test
case so what does the test case we are
going to write today so this is my news
case today so use case one as a user I
want to login to ebay application search
for JBL speakers and then I want to
check the today's team so there is
something called as the days D we will
go and click on that and see what are
the deals available I have another use
case here what says it from this website
from wherever we are right navigate to
the simple own website and navigate back
to the eBay door tail so this using this
use case 2 what I want to show you how
do we use the navigation commands and my
third use cases from the eBay door pane
I want to print the page title and close
the browser so with this we are trying
to demonstrate at least few commands
from each of the categories which we
talked about so I will be using Eclipse
for writing our test scripts
and if you want to know how to get
started with selenium how do we install
selenium you can refer to our videos on
installation of selenium by simply done
okay let me go to my Eclipse so in
Eclipse what I have done is I have
already created a project called
selenium demo and in this project I've
gone ahead and created a java class in
which we will be writing our test case
so the Java class which I have created
is eBay searched or Java and also what I
have done is if you look at few import
statements here I have imported all the
required selenium jars here so if you
look here in the referenced libraries
the way after we work with Java here
right so Java is the prereq for your
Eclipse so you already have the Java
libraries available here so what I need
to do is I also need to import the
selenium Jarvis and this is the list of
selenium jar files which you will need
to work with the Cellini and this I've
already imported for you then another
thing what I do as following a best
practice is instead of writing all my
code under this main function here what
I do is I create methods for each of the
use case or the test case which I'm
writing so same thing I am going to do
that today for all the use cases which
we have taken for this time now let's
get started so what is the first thing
which we need to do the first thing what
we need to do this you need to declare
your webdriver so which I've already
done you have set webdriver Drive and
then I need to launch the browser before
even I go into ebay dot in and start
performing two of their testing now for
me to launch further this is one method
which I've already written here so let
me walk you through this so there are
multiple steps we need to follow well
for launching the browser the first
thing is set system property so let's
understand this particular command here
the one which I have highlighted so this
is used to set the property for your
gecko driver now what is a gecko driver
if you remember why we are talking of
webdriver architecture I said for
whichever browser you want to work with
you need to tell the web driver as which
browser is what you are going to test it
and in my case here I'm going to be
using Firefox browser and also if you
remember while explaining the
architecture I said every browser every
browser has its own driver which you
need to download and install and where
is this driver let's go ahead and
see that on the selenium HQ dot watch it
so let me go to my Chrome browser I
already have a selenium HQ dot orgy
website open here now on this website in
the download section if you go down you
can see something called as third-party
drivers binding and plugins and here you
would see a list of all browsers gecko
driver chrome opera edge right and HTML
unit which is headless browser so all
this draws us with selenium supports
listed and for each of this browser we
have a driver associated with it which
we can download say if I want a gig or
driver what I need to do is I need to
click on this latest link this will take
me to the latest web driver which is
available so depending on the operating
system which you are using right now I'm
using a Mac so I've already downloaded
that so once you download you need to
place it in a particular direct ok so
let's go back to this and now if you see
this path here what I'm highlighting
this is where I have kept my gecko
driver
so this gecko driver what you see is my
executable so if you are using using a
Windows machine it will be geek or
driver dot exe so this is the driver
which should be working now coming back
to the system dot set properly
this particular method or this
particular command is used to set your
driver property it is a key value pair
and you will need to know which keys
depending on the which process you're
working with since I'm walking on the
Firefox browser the key which I need to
set is the web driver gecko dot driver
if I'm using Chrome what I simply do is
I have a key called Chrome and then I
would set this path to Chrome driver and
this is exactly you need to do so for
you to even before launch the browser
you need to do this set property so let
me change this back to gecko so now we
are clear till here now what is the next
command which we need to after setting
the property is after setting the
property you have to instantiate the web
driver which is done by using this
particular command driver is equal to
new Firefox tiger so once you do this
your browser is going to get launched
then once your browser is launched what
is the next step you do you would be
launching the application on which you
want to perform your test and that is
done by using the command which we just
saw no driver kit now since I'm going to
be working with eBay daughter I have
just said I would not get enter you are
fully formed URL so this particle
method is going to help me launch the
Firefox browser and also launch the eBay
application now advantage of using
methods like this is you can reuse this
methods in every test case which are
going to rate or you can make a common
function of this and just call this
function in any of your test cases now
for me to call this method what am I
going to do I'm going to create an
object of this class let's do that
object is equal to new tongue and then I
need to call this method obj dot launch
browser good so far
all right so now let's get to the first
use case so let's go back to our
presentation and see what was our first
use case our first use case was that we
want to launch the eBay application
which we have already done in the launch
browser method and then we want to
search for JBL speakers now for that
what we will do let me create a method
here so I will call this method as a
public void say search product that's my
method name so I have created a method
called search product now what I need to
do is I need to search for Jabin speaker
so for that let me go to my Firefox
browser and I need to first identify the
search box element so for identifying
what I do I go to this website I go to
this element and then I say inspect
element so now I know that there is
already an ID which is unique to this
particular web element available so I'm
going to make use of this ID I need to
go to my Eclipse so now here I'm going
to use the finite element method so for
that I'll say driver dot find element
I'll say bye dot ID and it's a string
argument I'll just copy the ID which I
copied from the Firefox browser and then
what is the operation I need to do here
I need to send keys and what are the
keys I need to set the product which I'm
searching for I am searching for say JBL
speakers done so with this command what
it will do is it will enter that X JBL
speakers in the search box after doing
this I need to click on the search
button now similarly I need to identify
what is the web element search for this
again I already have a unique ID here
which I am just going to simply copy
from here and use it in the find
elements so same thing I will do driver
dot find element by dot
and this is the ID of the button and
here what is my operation I need to
click that good so far now other thing
what we also need to understand sure is
so what happens sometimes depending on
the website some websites are pretty
slow even by loading the patient's arm
up pretty fast now for the selenium to
work without having to fail or without
having to create exception of not
finding the elements it is good to use
certain weights so why we need to use
weights and say for example when are
after entering the JBL speakers and
after clicking the button it's going to
take a while for it to search for JBL
speakers and give us that webpage with
the list of cheeping speakers and even
before we start doing the first command
like searching once we load the page it
takes time for the complete page to get
loaded
so selenium provides lot of
synchronization commands right and it's
a very big topic on its own which needs
to be used especially when you're
working with any kind of website okay so
there is a separate since it's a
separate topic as a separate video which
will help you understand how to use the
synchronization now for the demo purpose
we have certain weight commas which can
be used and that is exactly which I am
going to use here so that is called as
thread dot sleep so what this does is
say I'm going to give two thousand here
what this does is this basically the
script waits for two seconds right after
the previous command is executed and
then it executes your next command which
is our find element now this is showing
us an exception because it wants us to
add a exception here add throws
declaration which is interrupted
exception ok we need to do this so once
you are done ok we have done the click
so let's see what is the first use case
which we had have you covered everything
in the first use case ok we said login
to ebay done search for JBL speakers and
then i want to check on the days do we
need to do this also so for that again
what we need to do is we need to go and
identify so what I will do I'll use the
inspector here and look for this daily
deals now this is a link text it's an
anchor tag so what I will do I will copy
this link text daily deals I'll go to my
Eclipse now after this I will give
another thread dot sleep of say two
seconds that should be more than enough
and then I'll say driver dot
find element now this time I will be
using something called as link text and
here as an argument as a parameter I am
going to paste the daily things which I
just copied and then what do I need to
do on this web element I just need to do
a click operation yeah so the complete
first use case we have covered so what
we will do is let's go ahead and execute
this first use case now I have launched
the browser here I also need to call
this method which is search product now
again here since we are doing that ad
throw declaration on the method we also
need to do it for the main function
exception added I'll save this and for
me to run this what I do is I simply
right-click on that and I say run as
java application now we see that our
Firefox browser is launched the eBay
application is also launched and JBL
speakers entered and search clicked so
we have a list of JBL speakers here and
now as per our test case it has to go on
the daily deals which it just did right
all right so we have our first use case
working so right now I have not used the
browser not true so what I will do is
I'll just manually go and close this
process so we are done with our first
use case now let's move to our second
use case
so what second use case is is from
wherever you are right now we are on the
eBay eBay dot in navigate a simple on
website and then navigate back to eBay
Datuk so let's see how to handle that so
let's go back to my Eclipse here now
let's create another method instead of
saying test case to our use case ii will
give a mode meaningful name I'll say
navigate since we are exercising the
navigates come on navigate commands here
I'll just use this method now so we have
done the click so I need a quick thread
dot sleep here because I want it to wait
so that we can see otherwise it's going
to be so fast we will not be able to see
what are the operations in it so I'll
just add a thread dot sleep before we
start navigating to the new website ok
thread dot sleep and I guess two seconds
should be good enough even here so same
thing we need to add the exception so
add throws declaration and interrupted
exception all right done so now what we
need to do is we need to navigate to the
simple danke so for that first I need a
fully-formed URL of the web site which I
want to launch ok so let me go to and
here instead of ebay dot in I would say
the
search for simply long I have it here
and I just pick this from here
HTTP www.h lips and here we saw another
command like get we said I never get dot
too so let's use the same command so
I'll say driver dot navigate dot too and
I'm going to use to URL because or you
can just use a string because this is
going to be a string variable now what
does this command oh this will simply
navigate to the URL which we have
specified here now here again I'm going
to give a quick sleep here so that we
are able to see the website before we
navigate back to the eBay dot F so I'll
use a thread dot sleep this time
probably I'll give a three-second wait
then what does our use case say let's go
back to use case once in check and it
says and navigate back to ebay dot it so
that means I need to use a driver dot
navigate dot can you see the list of
commands here which provide for which
the navigate class provides okay and the
back is what we need to use so that it
comes back to the ebay dot it done so
far so good
now let's do one thing before even we go
to the use case three let's execute our
test case till here
so what I'll do I'll save this program
and after search product I will call
navigate method ok I will save this and
then right click run as java application
so our firefox is getting launched it is
launched the ebay application is on so
it's going to first find the JBL
speakers click on the search we have a
list of JBL speakers then it'll click on
the daily deals yes it is doing that we
got the deans of the day yes it is now
navigating to simply learned calm now
after three seconds it should take me
back to the ebay dot it ok cool so this
was the last page where we left before
we navigated to simply ok and that is
where we have come back using the backup
now let me close this again because i
have still not incorporated the driver
dot u s-- now let's look at this use
case three now use case three sales once
you're back to ebay dot in print the
page title and then close the process
very simple so we'll go back to eclipse
probably in the same method what I can
do is once I'm back here I will say so I
have to use driver dot get title that
spelling mistake driver dot get title
okay this is the method which we are
going to use to get the title of the
pitch now we also said that once we get
the page title we want to print it on
the console now how do you print it on
console you just use a 6 out statement
so instead of just writing this what I
will do is I will directly write this
out statement system dot out dot println
and I'll write a text as the title of
this page is and then we will
concatenate with driver dot get title as
simple as that and after I do this I
will simply call it's actually I want to
call the divert dot list but it's always
good to create a separate method so I'll
say public word close browser method and
here I'll simply say a driver dot quit
you can use closed or you can use quit
so let me demonstrate how do we use quit
here now I need to call the close
browser so simply what I do and say obj
dot close browser method ok so this
completes our all three use cases so now
let's execute all this three use cases
now and we should be able to see the
title of this page on the console so
same thing what I do is right click run
as java application ok same thing our
eBay is launched now send key with the
JBL speakers click on search button
executed and then it has to click on the
daily deals that it is done most to
simply learn website now it has to come
back to ebay dot N and we should be able
to see the closed process it just
happened at the snap of the finger right
now for us to know whether it really
happened what we have done is we have
printed the page title ok can you see
here we have the complete page title
printed here alright so let's go back so
let's look at what are the key takeaways
from that so in this overall video we
saw what was selenium what a selenium
webdriver what were the limitation of
the remote control which is selenium RC
how did webdriver replaced it and we
went into learning the architecture of
the selenium web browser which is very
important for us to understand because
we would be working with the webdriver
to create all our automation scripts and
then as I said every tool has its own
limitation we also talked about
limitations at a very high level and
so as there are workaround and then I
also demoed some of the browser APs and
their usages and some of the methods
which be used with selling it okay so
that brings us to the end of this video
and I hope you all enjoyed watching this
video do check out our other videos on
selenium-webdriver from scintilla thank
you very much and have a good day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here